beloved action star Bruce Willis and his
devastating battle with dementia this is
Entertainment Tonight Bruce's loved ones
revealing the news today now here
is on the Willis family's new heartbreak
here is Bruce just over a week ago
looking strong upbeat and even whistling
while out in LA with a friend today
Bruce's blended family who refer to
themselves as the ladies of Willis Moore
revealed his brain disease has
progressed to frontotemporal dementia
symptoms can include impaired judgment
loss of speech and no longer knowing the
meaning of words the statement revealed
quote challenges with communication are
just one symptom Bruce faces and there
are no treatments
ten months ago Bruce's Family First
revealed he was retiring from acting due
to his diagnosis with Aphasia the brain
disease also causes gradual loss of
speech and the ability to understand
language
the last time E.T spoke with Bruce was
in 2018 at the time his speech was
seemingly slower what's your favorite
memory from that
from Dion
I never really got hurt
yeah
got banged up but
but not but not bad it's unclear just
how much Bruce is able to currently
communicate but it seems like he can
still Express himself through music
last year Bruce's number one fan second
wife Emma Heming posted this jam session
saying quote Talent is speaking for
itself
[Music]